hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein ließ welt
heute startet wieder eine filmwoche das
heißt diese woche werde ich wieder
torten oder rezepte zu filmen machen
heute also diese woche habe ich leider
nur zwei filme das wirklich zeitlich nur
so gereicht hat und gerade nur die 2000
filme laufen und zwar ist heute unser
film dran samira und mein film und
nächstes mal ist moores film dran
heute geht es um rico oskar und den
diebstahl steinbrecher
politisch ist ein ganz toller kinderfilm
und zwar sind es drei teile insgesamt
und das ist jetzt der dritte und letzte
teil und zwar so dass die verfilmungen
zu den büchern von andreas steinhöfel
stein nicht steigern soll extrudiert
meinhövel kinderbuchautor und im film
geht es darum da ist einmal der
hochbegabte oskar und der tief begabte
rico also so ungefähr wie murat und ich
gebe auf jeden fall geht es um die
beiden jungs sind befreundet und die
erleben immer ganz viele bunte abenteuer
zusammen
und dieses mal gehen sie alleine auf
reisen und erleben ganz viel ist vor
allen dingen streiten sie sich in diesem
film zum ersten mal das nicht immer ganz
wichtig dass kinder sich auch mal
streiten weil man muss ja auch lernen
sich wieder zu versöhnen und ich würde
sagen wir schauen uns einfach kurzen
trailer an oder noch ganz kurz die sehr
steigen verschwindet genau das macht es
halt ganz vergessen
genau der stein verschwindet also wird
die most genau der ricoh hat nämlich
seine stein sammlung und der erfindet
also er denkt ist etwas ganz besonderes
und sein freund oskar sagt dass ich
bestimmt nichts besonderes und hat
keinen wert
und dieser eine stein dieser diebstahl
stein der verschwindet und dann
versuchen sie neben wieder zurück zu
bekommen genau dann spielt es in rust
genau spiele aus problem und ich mag
deutsche filme sowieso ganz gerne genau
aber realistischen ich bin die amaryllis
tisch er vor allem der 'tatort' antrags
jawohl sonntags 20.15 aber jetzt gemacht
rico und oskar sinn zurück darf ich nun
mal den kalkstein sind mit einem neuen
spannenden abenteuer interessiert das
geheimnis des gestohlenen kalksteins für
die beiden detektive bis an die ostsee
noch unterm tisch versteckt morgen 16
uhr am fkk strand am strand
was du da nach tag 2 mutter lauter
nackten viel wie einkaufen
hallo
nach dem bestseller von andreas
steinhöfel ins haus stehen suchen und
was eigentlich verkaufen
ihr größtes abenteuer ganz wundervoll
gestein gehört mir und ich soll auf ihn
aufpassen also gebt dem jungen seinen
kufstein wieder kapstadt
reißt
rico oskar und der diebstahl stein damit
automatisch lauf und wie viele die
wurzel aus 18 zahnwurzel ab 28 april nur
im kino
das war jetzt der kurze trailer ich bin
schon richtig gespannt auf den film und
wir werden ja öfter mal gefragt ob er
denn nicht rezepte oder torten zu
bestimmten filme machen möchten und ich
suche mir dann die filme immer aus also
wenn sie zu mir passen und zu einem
kanal passen meist natürlich ganz gerne
es gab natürlich auch schon filme
moratti habe ich auch gesagt ja auf
jeden fall finde ich immer ganz schön
vor allem weil man so immer ganz viele
tolle trocken kreieren kann sowie
erzählt diese schatztruhe
bei dieser schatztruhe ist es so ich
habe jetzt hier einen schokoladenkuchen
den sich samira gewünscht hat eigentlich
wollte jetzt auch mit dabei sein aber
sie eingeschlafen und jetzt habe ich
hier unten einen schokokuchen und oben
der deckel dass es auch im schokokuchen
gefühlt habe ich mit einer schokoladen
ghana und am dekoriert dann mit diesen
goldmünzen also ich finde es richtig
hübsch geworden und es ist gar nicht so
schwierig wie es vielleicht auf den
ersten blick aussieht
deswegen nehme ich euch jetzt mit ich
habe dafür insgesamt drei tage gebraucht
und jeden tag immer mal wieder ein paar
schritte gemacht dann kann man sich das
nämlich ganz gut ein sagt nicht drei
tage lang nicht die harnisch drei volle
tage 23 stunden und daraus diese torte
entstanden genau starten jetzt direkt
mit der torte ich zeig euch wie das
alles funktioniert ich werde jetzt
zuerst einmal den teig zubereiten und
zwar habe ich da den saftigen
schokoladen teig vorbereitet den ich
gerne für motiv torten nehmen denn da
ist auch richtig schön stabile und ich
kann ihn zurecht schneiden
ich werde den teig jetzt in zwei
backform und backen ich habe zweimal den
eckigen back rahmen vorbereitet und zwar
habe ich den auf 20 x 30 cm eingestellt
denn die schatztruhe soll später eine
größe von 20 x 10 cm und bei dem
programm das ist also dann kann ich mir
nämlich statt drei teigplatten
zurechtschneiden und ich nehme dann noch
eine eckige backformen kasten backform
und die hat auch 20 x 10 cm
wer zb aber eine rehrücken format so wie
diese hier kann auch die benutzten
denn da hat man schon diese rundung die
man später für die schatzkiste braucht
normalerweise hätte ich jetzt auch die
genommen aber ich denke dass die einfach
wenige von euch haben deswegen
wachsendem in der eckigen kastenform und
zeigt euch dann später wenn man den teig
zu recht schneidet die kasten backform
muss jetzt noch mit etwas backpapier
ausschneiden stift kann ich jetzt
erstmal hier klicken und dann schön
anpassen und die traktion die teile
jetzt auf und zwar kommt der größte teil
natürlich in die große backform und
kleiner teilen kommt dann in die
kastenform die völlig so etwa bis zur
hälfte den backofen habe ich jetzt auf
160 grad ober unterhitze vorgeheizt die
kastenform braucht bei mir jetzt etwa 40
minuten
der bug namen braucht etwa 30 minuten
und nach dem backen zeig ich euch mal
das endergebnis und zeige euch auch wie
die verschiedenen teile dann aussehen
und was es eben für ein unterschied
macht in der kastenform oder in den bug
rahmen zu packen
die tigers sind jetzt gebacken und ich
habe es auch etwas abkühlen lassen
so sehen die teil geht es übrigens aus
die im direkten vergleich also hier
einmal im bug rahm und backen sie immer
schön flach und in backformen bekommen
sie immer so einen hügel in der mitte
das ist jetzt bei dieser torte nicht
schlimm deich später sowieso eine kuppel
brauche und die lasse ich jetzt über
nacht komplett abgedeckt
vorher aber mit einem geschirrtuch
weiter dann noch eine zahl peter
karrasch herstellen und die torte morgen
befüllen und dekorieren jetzt am
nächsten tag sind die teigboden
abgekühlt und ich werde die tak böden
jetzt mit einer schokoladen kenner schon
aprikosenmarmelade befüllen denn die
samira wünscht sich eine reine
schokoladentorte dafür habe ich jetzt
hier etwas aprikosenmarmelade mit wasser
vermischt mit etwas flüssiger wird und
habe hier noch eine schokoladen garage
mit zartbitterschokolade vorbereitet
kann ich die tortenböden reis lösen
jetzt kann ich direkt die große
tortenplatte zerschneiden und zwar
möchte ich da jetzt die drei teile
auseinander schneiden die dann 20
zentimeter lang und 10 cm breit sind
habe ich im cache bord das passt auch
ganz gut es hat einen zentimeter stärke
und ist von der größe her 30 x 25 cm
groß da passt jetzt die schatztruhe gut
drauf und ich kann eben noch richtig
schön aus warum dekorieren
da setze ich jetzt direkt in unteren
teil drauf das heißt hier mit ich kommt
etwas gar auf da braucht man keine
zwischen platte denn ich kann das alles
direkt auf dieser servierplatten dann
auch dekorieren und bevor ich jetzt die
anderen drauf setzte muss ich natürlich
erst die marmelade mit dem wasser
erhitzen und kann dann die tortenböden
damit bestreichen
sobald sich die marmelade dann mit dem
wasser verbunden hat und aufgelöst hat
kann ich jetzt direkt den tortenboden
damit bestreichen den ob jetzt übrigens
noch ein stück zurück gesetzt damit ich
später vornehmer platz habe für die
dekoration und jetzt wird der teig
richtig schön damit getränkt dadurch
wird der teig auch etwas deftiger und
man kann eben auch geschmack mit rein
bekommen
ich war einfach kurz bis es hier
eingezogen ist die anderen teigplatten
drehe ich einfach rum und drängte jetzt
hier schon mal könnt ihr auch gut
einziehen und ich kann gleich die torte
mit ghanas bestreichen
kann ich die torte direkt mit der kasse
gefüllt
da kommt jetzt der zweite boten drauf da
wird genauso befüllt und dann kommt da
anschließend auf der dritte boden drauf
damit an der torte weiter arbeiten kann
muss sie erstmal in den kühlschrank und
in der zeit kann ich schon mal den
zweiten oberen teil befüllen diesen
kuchen werde ich jetzt mit einer torten
segnitzer teilen und zwar mache ich das
hier zweimal da kann ich dir nämlich
auch gut fühlen und er bekommt noch
etwas an höhe
die obere platte setzt sich auf eine
kupferplatte das ist eine leichte platte
aber es geht zum beispiel auch einfach
so ein kleines pub stück das habe ich
jetzt auch zugeschnitten auf 10 x 20 cm
bestreikt mit garage und setzte den
unteren teil direkt drauf dann wird es
genauso befüllt wie die untere torte
auch erst mit aprikosenmarmelade und
dann mit ghana
der kuchen ist schön abgekühlt jetzt
kann ich ihn zurecht schneiden und wir
wie gesagt eine runde form benutzt also
eine reform können euch diesen teil
sparen
es müsste ich praktisch hier oben so ein
kleiner halbkugel denken und könnt dann
hier die ränder wegschneiden und die
kann man dann beispielsweise benutzen um
cake pops zu machen und als es ganz
hilfreich wenn ihr euch von innen nach
außen arbeitet zuerst die eine hälfte
dann drehe ich den kuchen um und dann
kommt die andere hälfte
sie einen rändern so läuft die torte
jetzt so ganz leicht nach außen und hier
an den kanten habe ich das so ein
bisschen angeschrägt als zu einem
kleinen winkel reingeschnitten da mal
was später noch richtig schöne form für
die schatztruhe
jetzt hätte ich den deckel der
schatztruhe ganz dünn mit einer garage
streichen
lass dir dann etwa 15 minuten im
kühlschrank und dann kommt noch eine
ganze schicht drauf die zwischenzeit
kann ich jetzt nutzen um auch die untere
torte mit kanals zu bestreichen und
sobald die die erste schicht drauf hat
die krümel schicht werde ich die andere
torte komplett glattstreichen
der kurier setz dich gekühlt und jetzt
kommt da die zweite schicht drauf die
sollte möglichst glatt sein damit gleich
die von bosch ist schön glatt auflegen
kann diese rundungen könnt ihr am besten
richtig glatt abziehen mit einer
tankkarte deswegen streiche ich zuerst
die garage immer mit der palette auf und
schießt dann mit der zeitkarte ganz
klappt wird noch der untere teil glatt
gestrichen
da ist jetzt nur wichtig dass die seiten
platz sind da oben ist nicht wichtig
denn die wird später durch die
goldstücke verdeckt
hier beim eckigen kuchen für nicht immer
ganz praktisch mit so einer tankkarte zu
arbeiten die in den schönen rechten
winkel hat denn hier kann ich sehen wenn
ich die tankkarte ansätze so einfach nur
ein bisschen masse fehlt hier zum
beispiel unten
dann kann ich nämlich mit der palette
noch ein bisschen kanada anbringen und
das ganz glatt mit der tankkarte
abziehen
das ist übrigens eigentlich gar keine
teig karte sondern seine gemüse hacker
also man kann damit so kennen wir sagen
aber es eignet sich eben richtig gut der
bekannten schön ansetzen und die
überreste da oben die kann ich dann ganz
nach mit einem messer wegschneiden der
kuchen da ist oben jetzt gar nicht
perfekt man kann hier natürlich noch
glätten wenn man möchte aber man muss es
wirklich gar nicht da ist auch hier
etwas höher als hier aber das ist gar
nicht stimmt könnte wirklich so lassen
hauptsache die seiten sind etwas gerade
jetzt stelle ich dann auch noch kurz in
den kühlschrank und kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit schon mal die hände waschen
und dann nach meinen schocke von doc
nähten
da brauche ich jetzt etwa 500 bis 750
gramm habe etwa 500 gramm schoko von der
weiß geknetet und werde diesen jetzt auf
etwas becker strecke auf 3 mm dünn
ausrollen
dafür habe ich hier so zwei holzstäbe
und damit es auch richtig schön
gleichmäßig
ich freue mich nach der höchsten stelle
an der torte
das ist bei mir etwas 74 cm und dann
setze ich da einfach noch ein paar
millimeter dran also gehe ich auf circa
78 und trolle jetzt auch die streifen
dementsprechend aus und schneidet sie
eben zu recht dann kann ich nämlich an
alle vier seiten
diese platten setzen und habe schöne
gerade kanten und entweder nehmen dir
jetzt dafür ein lineal und einen cutter
oder in marzipan messer oder einem teig
rädchen so wie hier die kann ich jetzt
schön einstellen und kann dann alle
gleichzeitig schneiden
um jetzt etwas arbeit zu ersparen werde
ich die teig streifen jetzt so
zurechtschneiden dass ich zwei streifen
haben und die dann jeweils hier an die
lange und an die kurze seite setzte also
dass es so um die ecke geht
das heißt ich muss jetzt einmal die
lange seite abmessen
das sind hier fast 20 cm aber dann ist
da wirklich etwas genau messen also 19,9
und dann kommt da noch die kurze seite
dran und die kurze seite sind jetzt etwa
9,6 also hab ich jetzt ungefähr 29
so und damit etwas einfacher ist rolle
ich jetzt diesen streifen auf ein
kleines stückchen auf und befeuchtet die
torte mit etwas back trend spray jetzt
kann ich die rolle hier am rand ansetzen
und grenze abholen
dann könnt ihr die freundin hatte direkt
mit diesem von am theater an drücken
aber ganz perfekt machen beide platten
auflegen
und an diesen ecken empfiehlt es sich
immer mit zwei kindern zu arbeiten mit 2
1 vorn antreten und zwar müsse die immer
so ein bisschen aneinander drücken und
dann entsteht eine richtig schöne ecke
und überreste von der bäcker stärke kann
man immer ganz gut mit einem ganz großen
trockenen pinsel weg bevor davon und
jetzt an trocknet werde ich mit einem
modell werkzeug mit seiner modelle
pinsel so ein bisschen holzstruktur
einritzen
beim deckel werde ich jetzt zuerst die
beiden äußeren teile überziehen und da
mache ich jetzt so dass ich jetzt ein
stück hiervon anleger dann glatt strecke
und dann schneide ich drum herum
zuerst ganz grob und dann kann man die
feinheiten noch mal mit dem cuttermesser
abschneiden und für den oberen bereich
muss ich jetzt eine platte ausrollen
beziehungsweise zurechtschneiden die so
breit ist wie der deckel
ich mache ein paar millimeter mehr und
bevor ich sie darüber läge streiche ich
hier an die rinde noch ein bisschen
s-bahn zucker kleber
und hier schneide ich zuerst unten die
kante weg und dann an den rändern und
jetzt werde ich auch den deckel der
schatztruhe mit einem modell werkzeug
etwas strukturieren die zweit offen
lasse ich jetzt im kühlschrank 100 jetzt
schon mal ein paar dekoelemente
vorbereiten
die müssen nämlich bis morgen noch durch
trocknen damit ich sie dann auf die
torte setzen kann
dafür habe ich jetzt schwarze modell der
schublade genommen und damit die teile
noch besser aus herzen nehme ich etwas
zellulose pulver und knete das 1
wenn ich jetzt so ungefähr ein viertel
teelöffel auf 100 gramm oder schokolade
die modelle schokolade auch 3 mm dünn
aus mit nämlich so einen rechteckigen
ausstecher stich doch zwei teile aus
dann mache ich nämlich zwei schnallen an
die torte
brauche ich für die zwei schnallen
nochmal zwei teile
die strecke aber jetzt ein bisschen
kleiner
und jetzt werde ich hier unten jeweils
ein kleines schlüsselloch reinmachen
und jetzt kennzeichne ich hier noch so
ein paar nieten oder nägel das mache ich
jetzt mit einer ganz kleinen loch thüle
dann brauche ich noch mal zwei größere
teile für die seiten
jetzt freu' mich noch einen ganz dünnen
langen strang und daraus wir dann einen
ring gemacht den ring lege ich jetzt
hier hinten zusammen dem kamel selbst
leben muss man aber nicht denn der wird
jetzt gleich verdeckt und zwar von
diesem teil
das drücke ich jetzt hier so ein
bisschen dran dann sieht man nämlich
auch dass der regen darunter durchgeht
und es wird dann später wenn es
getrocknet ist an den rand geklebt die
teile lassen jetzt hier erstmal trocknen
und werde jetzt nur noch die perlenkette
vorbereiten ich reise mit schokolade und
da dies nicht ganz hart werden muss und
mir das ausreicht oder konsistenz dass
ich dir jetzt so knete kein 10c prüfer
ein
die perlenkette könnte jetzt ganz
gleichmäßig machen und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier diesen langen strang und
schneit dann immer gleich große teile
runde und die form ich dann einzeln zu
kugeln
jetzt nehme ich ein silber pulver und
gibt es in ein etwas größeres gefäß da
kann ich jetzt nämlich die kugeln rhein
geben und dann bekommt die diesen
schönen berglern schütteln und dann
haben die den schönen schimmer die
schloss elemente und die perlen das
jetzt bis morgen durch trocknen und
werden morgen die torte noch
zusammensetzen
ich bin jetzt am dritten tag heute
welches torte zusammensetzen und auch
servieren
und jetzt werde ich noch die restlichen
dekoelemente fertig machen die kann man
natürlich auch gerne schon vorher machen
aber ich habe es mir jetzt auch heute
aufgehoben
und zwar werde ich jetzt aus etwas
vanille von dort eine schatzkarte
zeichnen und ausschneiden und zwar habe
ich denn von dort etwas 10 10 wieder mit
zellulose verknetet damit die
schatzkarte schön austrocknet
der vanille von da eignet sich dafür
richtig gut denn da ist ja nicht ganz
weiß sondern eher so ein alt weiß und
deswegen finde ich hat er echt schon die
perfekte farbe schneide ich das einfach
ganz grob mit einem pizzaschneider
zurecht das muss auch nicht ganz gerade
sein und damit die schatzkarte jetzt
auch richtig alt aussieht werde ich hier
an den rändern noch immer bisschen mit
einem kater praktisch die karte peter
stören also einschneiden
damit die karte jetzt als von verbrannt
aussieht werde ich jetzt noch braune und
schwarze lebensmittel farbpulver nehmen
und wartet jetzt einfach damit pinseln
immer ein bisschen am rand am rand darf
so etwas dunkler sein und da auch ein
bisschen schwarz mit rein und in der
mitte darf sie noch hell bleiben
bei der karte ist jetzt wichtig dass man
auch die rückseite wenigstens an den
rändern so ein bisschen bemalt denn die
karte wird gleich noch ein bisschen
aufgerollt und dann würde man das sehen
als ich noch ein bisschen am rand und
jetzt nehme ich einen cake pops stick
entwickelt hier oben die eine ecke ein
und dann auch hier unten die
gegenüberliegende ecke hat so ein
bisschen karte ziehen jetzt noch auf
meine schaumstoff platte und legt dann
hier auf den an unter die anderen ecken
august runter dann sieht sie ein
bisschen echter aus und dann kann ich
sie jetzt erstmal antrocknen lassen und
später dann noch bemalen
jetzt mache ich mit der torte weiter da
nehme ich jetzt gerade wieder den
gleichen pinsel wie eben und noch einen
kleineren und dann kann ich mit brauner
und schwarzpulver farbe auch hier so ein
bisschen tiefer mit rein geben vor allem
in den rillen kann man ganz gut mit
dunklem schwarz und braun arbeiten und
dann zieht die torte gleich noch
hübscher aus
als nächstes mache ich sie schon fertig
und zwar schwarze modell schokolade
bereits ausgerollt und die schneide ich
jetzt in dünne streifen
jetzt kann man die streifen so schwarz
lassen ich werde jetzt allerdings damit
etwas hübscher aussieht noch gold machen
und zwar mit dem gold bruder
dafür lege ich jetzt hier auf ein stück
papier und dann kann ich direkt mit dem
gold puder drauf oder und dann werde ich
die streifen mit etwas kleber ankleben
dann gebe ich jetzt hier ganz dünn drauf
kannst dann drüber legen und dann auch
gleich abschneiden
und hier mag jetzt wieder ein paar nägel
mit meiner kleinen spritztour
jetzt muss ich nur noch die getrockneten
teile die ich gestern bereits
vorbereitet habe mit gold bepinseln und
dann auch noch ankleben
jetzt werde ich für vor die schatzkarte
ganz durchgetrocknet noch die chipkarte
bemalen und zwar mache ich das mit
lebensmittelfarbstoff ne in schwarz und
rot vielleicht nämlich noch ein bisschen
grün und mal ein bisschen was drauf
jetzt muss ich eigentlich nur noch die
einzelnen elemente zusammen stellen und
zwar kann ich jetzt erstmal die
perlenkette machen und dafür pc eine
nadel mit faden und werde jetzt ganz
einfach die perlen hier auf spießen und
dann müssen die beiden enden oder
verknotet werden
jetzt möchte ich noch das skateboard
überziehen dafür für mich etwas wasser
mit puderzucker und zwar so dass es
schön dickflüssig ist jetzt streiche ich
die masse ganz dünn of platte auf und
dann klebe ich da so ein paar streusel
drauf und zwar habe ich hier löffel bis
jetzt ganz fein zerbröseln mit dem mixer
und dann sieht es aus wie ganz feiner
sand jetzt setzt sich die torte zusammen
und zwar möchte ich dass die schatztruhe
halb geöffnet ist deswegen komplett ein
bisschen kanal schafft die oberfläche
damit ich so eine kleine erhöhung habe
und auch damit an klärt ich habe hier
zwei cake pops ticks die stecke ich
jetzt hier ein die sorgen dann dafür
dass die obere torte nicht in die untere
einzige und aus der decke leben geöffnet
bleibt
da kommt jetzt auch ein bisschen ganache
drauf einfach damit alles gut leben kann
das muss jetzt auch gar nicht so sauber
sein denn diese stellen die werden alle
gleich verdeckt mit dem ganzen gold das
kann ich die torte draufsetzen
ganz leicht andrücken jetzt fühle ich
den zwischenraum noch mit diesem
goldmünzen kleine auf und die lege ich
jetzt einfach mit rein was man jetzt
auch nicht vergessen sollte es die
perlenkette sie lege ich nämlich auch
hier rein und kann da dann gleich noch
ein paar münzen drüber leben
zum fixieren der perlenkette da hinten
kann man einfach zum beispiel ein
zahnstocher nehmen und es war ein pixel
und die dann schön hinlegen
dann fehlen da oben nur noch die
schnallen
jetzt noch ein paar essbar diamanten
dies setze ich jetzt auch mit drauf die
passen wirklich super und die diamanten
fasse ich jetzt nicht mit den fingern
sondern mit einer pinzette an
denn sobald er mit den fettigen fingern
an diesen zucker geht wird das später
mal und ist ziemlich schade
zuletzt mache ich jetzt noch den
diebstahl stein also den stein um den
ist die ganze zeit eigentlich schon im
film geht man kann den jetzt auch zwei
verschiedene arten herstellen einerseits
so wie ich es mache ganz einfach oder
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch so ein rock
candy machen
den müssten aber dann schon einen tag
vorher machen und zwar bitte einfach
seine form aus von dort gemacht und war
filter so einen sirup hineinklettern
später kristallisiert die modelle
schokolade habe ich jetzt schon vor
geknetet und damit sie ein bisschen
struktur bekommt knete ich dass diese
zuckerkristalle ein also diesen dekor
zucker jetzt sehe ich noch ein paar rote
kristalle denn der leuchtet nämlich ein
bisschen rot rosa gehört so ein bisschen
weiße pulver farbe und tupfte einfach so
ein bisschen drüber dann bekommt das
stein noch ein bisschen struktur
die torte jetzt fertig samira gefällst
du dir ja mir gefällt es auch richtig
gut denn je um einen diebstahl stein und
hier sind so miraß steine
mein rekord oscar der am ende steht eine
stein sammlung gern im irak haben die
kirchen gebracht ist ja wir zeigen wir
schneiden jetzt direkt mal an oder
eigentlich eine mit halbieren
aufschneiden aber ich glaube ich schon
doch am rand immer so eine ecke weg
jedenfalls wenn man sie anschneidet
natürlich hat man irgendwo den deckel
auf den teller legen
nato-kriegsschiffe goldmann schneiden
sollte man vorher die münzen natürlich
wegnehmen
bitteschön die münze hier wurde zur
telekom auch essen ja und jetzt schneide
ich hier was okay nein ich zuerst aber
wenn mir nichts passiert dann darfst du
es okay lass mich probieren wenn wir
nichts passiert dann darfst du essen
abgemacht
von draußen rum deutsche immer ein
bisschen fester richtig schokoladiger
schokokuchen der volksschule von dollar
ja deswegen schmeckt er innen und außen
gut und wie schmeckt da muss aber
ehrlich sein mir schmeckt schätzen
du machst aber spannend sondern gab auch
ein stück hingeben darf ich da was
abreißt wie kannst du bist nicht so viel
kannst mit schoko wunder wie bei mir rat
gesagt nicht so viel du darfst nicht so
viel erzählt jetzt gibt's noch ein
gewinnspielen und zwar wurden uns wieder
preise zur verfügung gestellt die seht
ihr hier
ich habe vier tolle gewinnt preise und
zwar sind jeweils zwei kinotickets mit
dabei ein link t shirts genau und eine
turbulente beutel und einer kam sogar zu
viel ich glaube das ist der turnbeutel
für dich fürs fitnessstudio genau jetzt
hat wieder eine seite und ich habe
beschlossen das trikot fisch und ich bin
oscar jetzt was ihr dafür tun müsst um
die rtl frage nochmal wenig um ein heißt
du bist aber dafür verantwortlich okay
also rtl frage lautet defekte teil der
trilogie ist das jetzt das noch mal eine
richtige frage und ihr dürft gerne
teilnehmen und unten in den kommentaren
eure antworten schreiben und wie jedes
mal bei so film kooperationen werden mit
die gewinnerin aussuchen und dann
einfach schriftlich benachrichtigen
das ganze läuft an eine woche ohne frage
aber das weiß ich ganz genau
sie muss irgendwie in dem film spielt
eine ehemalige viva-moderatorin mit witz
war mit
wie heißt diese dame selbst rote haare
ab und macht werbung für ok ich weiß es
auch
also falls ihr die antwort kennt welche
viva-moderatorin damit spielt dann
schreibt mir in die kommentare
vielleicht zeit ihr einmal hab ich doch
sagt ach so ja vielleicht seid ihr eine
der glücklichen murat weser an den
gewinner aus und wir werden euch dann
schriftlich benachrichtigen
und falls ihr auch seine schatztruhe
backen wollt dann geht auf meinem blog
sales - blog.de da steht nämlich noch
mal alle zutaten mengen ganz genau und
wir werden diesen kugel jetzt aufteilen
du nimmst du bist was mit und dieser mir
an dem bis mitte kindergarten morgen und
dann ist ja auch ganz schnell
aufgegessen also bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss samira flüge